Yes Lauren, some of you may remember the case of my brother David. He was the
one who was hit by a car riding his bike home back from work. And he was in a
coma for couple of weeks, and then vegetative for a few months. And he suffered
both kinds of amnesia, retrograde and anterior grade. So for instance in
retrograde, he would forget about the 9 months prior to the accident, so we
asked him, for instance, who his roommates were, who he lived with during that
period. He could not tell us. Likewise, interiograde amnesia, he would forget
new events, after the accident. So, for instance, he meet somebody and then the
next day. Meet him again, he's completely forgotten ever having met them. So he
suffered both retrograde and anterograde amnesia.